welcome to a public lecture sponsored by
Center for Latin American and Iberian
studies please be sure to join us for a
reception on the second floor after this
lecture and there you will be encouraged
if you want a glass of wine to sign up
for the center's mailing list of
lectures Gustavo's what the era's will
also speak tomorrow at this time at st.
Thomas More center and at three o'clock
in the afternoon tomorrow at the center
he will celebrate Mass and preach he
will not be preaching tomorrow at the
Divinity School in the year 1701 this is
before your times was well a collegiate
school was founded in old saybrook
Connecticut the reason for the founding
of the institution was clearly stated
quote for the educating and instruction
of youth in good literature arts and
sciences so that by the blessings of
Almighty God they may be better fitted
for public employment both in church and
in civil state banquet the initial
enrollment was two young men 17 years
later the school was moved to New Haven
and renamed Yale College the new site
for the institution had to do in part
with the unique physical design of a
city of New Haven in the middle of the
previous century the town had been laid
out as nine perfect squares each square
500 cubits wide by five hundred cubits
long the design and the measurements are
found in the Old Testament book of the
prophet Ezekiel chapter 45 this was the
urban plan of utopian Jerusalem a sacred
metropolis that the reverend john
davenport wish to establish on a stretch
of land in front of two outcroppings of
granite also mentioned by the biblical
prophet as sacred mountains today they
are called east rock and west rock
locating yell at the heart of this
religious landscape was a logical
consequence of its identity to quote
educate youth for public employment in
the church hence from its very founding
Yale saw one of its primary goals as the
formation of students in ministerial
studies and the teaching of the subject
called theology that is faith seeking
understanding and praxis in fact you
might say that in its beginnings Yale
was a rather monkish place to live
although I don't think that the Puritan
founders would have used that word
throughout the 19th century Yale men
were woken up at five o'clock in the
morning they quickly dressed rarely
showered and went to the chapel at 515
for prayers at six o'clock in the
morning they had a breakfast that
consisted of a half loaf of bread and a
mug of beer
I have been told that some
undergraduates continue that tradition
today not the early hour nor the prayers
just the breakfast then the Yale men
went to class from seven to three in the
afternoon and studied the biblical
languages of Hebrew Greek and Latin and
related material Yale students were only
allowed to speak Latin even during their
recreation time but it seems that it was
rarely enforced well times have
certainly changed and the two words that
certainly do not apply to Yale today or
monkish or puritanical for the question
of the place of religion in the public
and secular sphere remains perhaps with
more interest and urgency in recent
years and under recent global
circumstances it also remains a concern
of an academic institution like Yale
University a significant contributor to
that dialogue of faith in the secular
sphere is the man who will speak to us
today father Gustavo Gutierrez was born
and raised in Lima Peru he is a priest
of the Dominican Order and when not
teaching in Lima or in Rome he is the
John Cardinal O'Hara O'Hara professor of
theology at the University of Notre Dame
best known as the founder of liberation
theology he studied medicine literature
psychology philosophy and theology and
obtained a doctorate from the Catholic
University of Lyon France he also holds
honorary degrees from twenty other
universities and has been awarded the
principe de asturias prize by the
spanish government and the Legion of
Honor prize by the French government for
his work for human dignity and against
oppression his 1971 groundbreaking work
entitled a theology of liberation
history politics salvation explains his
notion of loving solidarity with
poor as well as being a protest against
poverty he has written more than a dozen
books and hundreds of articles
concerning the church's role in creating
social structures of solidarity and when
he is not dictating class or writing Don
Gustavo is the pastor of a tiny parish
congregation in the Lima barrio of
remark his greatest joy is feeding
breakfast to the local children a luxury
that most of them do not have please
help me welcome Gustavo Gutierrez
you
well first of all men thanks for this
invitation and to have the opportunity
to share with you some reflections about
the situation of the poor people in in
Latin America and the witness of a key
person in our recent history keep their
soul not only in the Christian milieu
but the young beyond this because the
witness of Romero is very present in
different persons in in my continent
many thanks to high math for his
introduction and to you for your
presence here this evening
in the in the middle of the poverty
operation and sufferings of his people
it seems to me Oscar Romero was a
witness of all it was it seems to me his
great message in one moment he has
written this for example we have only a
value to provide home it seems strange
because the situation was so difficult
so bad and he has tried to rise the hope
of his people and the people of the
whole Latin America I would like to
present some reflections about his about
this witness and the fundaments of his
witness for him I have three three parts
1 speaking of Romero as a person of two
memories second some considerations of
water Christianity in history because he
was really very committed who is the
daily life of his people and finally to
come again a question of hope to see it
hope well
maybe you have already observant I have
some difficulties in your language but
you difficulties by experience I can say
will be above all in the beginning
because my mistakes always the same
first point Romero a person of two
memories the prophets in the Bible
recalls the presence of God in human
history and the yard persons over to
memories the memory of God the memory of
the love of God and the memory of the
people especially the poor people
certainly interrelated these two
memories but clearly they are the
witness of this it seems to me Romero a
saprophytic voice he was a preacher his
homilies he also written his homilies we
have several volumes of his holiness and
through this work the homily it is easy
to see he was really a profit but profit
as I have taken this word in the
biblical meaning they lobby the person
speaking instead God it is the day in
the roll over the Prophet at the
prophetic word is nourished who is
contemplation of
contemplation of the outer world several
a text in the Bible about profits are
speaking about this but it is an nourish
also by silence because silence is a
condition to listen and Romero said this
quote I feel the people is my profit the
people the poor people that is to say
the people is speaking to me instead of
God we know very well this sentence
coming from the Gospel of John if the
word weekends I know the Word was made
flesh well if it is true we can say this
in the mission of Romero the suffering
flesh of the Salvadorian people was made
world the flesh the suffering flesh he
was speaking often about they suffered
in flesh darkness affluent a suffering
flash for him with synonymous to seek to
say a person but concretely a person
suffering and in this sense we can say
he is a prophet but maybe some words
about the minim in the bible of memory
memory is a subject that pervades the
whole Bible it's a central notion in
both Testaments but in the Bible memory
is not principally and certainly not
exclusively related to the past the
first link of memory is with the present
the past is there in memory but only to
give some business to the present moment
of the believer Santa boost in a house
Capulet very well the meaning the
vehicle meaning of memory when he wrote
memory is the present of the past
present of the past memory is not the
history of the past times always in the
Bible is rather to keep in mind the
present knowledge certainly by the
experience of the past what is the
present an another characteristic of one
of memory in the Bible is this but is
beyond concepts memory is oriented to
the transformation of reality the
historical social reality memory is this
going to this and to change the moment
and is oriented to act without these 22
points memory related to present a
memory related to action memories only
an intellectual gymnastics to recall to
be cold but the Bible
these two questions present and
transformation of reality are of central
points in memory to finish with the
notion of memory is an expression of the
gods love to speak about the memory of
God is to speak about the love of God
and it is good for vessels also when the
Bible is speaking about the memory of
the people is the memory of the love of
God in the memory they must love their
neighbors for coalition we speak about
to memories well this is very well known
this expression of suggestions according
to look enter same problem do this in
memory of me it is institution we call
this normally destitution of the
Eucharist do this in memory of me and
what is good too and in the light of
someone my considerations about memory
to understand why this this affirmation
do this in memory of me is not only to
to repeat the right the Last Supper is
not only to remember the death and the
resurrection of Jesus is the memory of
the life witness teachings and other
gestures is the memory of the whole life
do this in memory of me is keep in your
memory my witness my presence among you
this is a communitarian memory we are
doing these in community not only
individually and I am NOT in one text of
Romero a Romero I said the Christian
people are the people that live on a
memory the remembrance of the girls but
not like a memory of the past it is
memory that becomes present still more
becomes whole of the future it is very
faithful to the biblical meaning a
memory one memory this remembrance of
the witness the life offer of Jesus the
second one is this as you know the three
synoptic Gospels Matthew Mark Luke a are
telling the institution of the Eucharist
and we have not these in the Gospel of
John John it is true John is really very
free as a freelance different to other
Gospels and so and we have not this but
even physically in the gospel in the
place of the older Gospels are speaking
about they do this in memory of me John
prasanta a little fact a color we we
know this for the Holy Week the washing
of feet of the disciples it seems a
little strange apparently
no big relation and but to wash the feet
of the disciples was a sign of her very
humble service two persons two other
persons and at the end over this this
manner to present the washing of feet in
the Gospel of John it is said this I
have justice' speaking to his disciples
i have given to do a model to follow a
model to wash the feet of a is a model
to follow so i have done for you should
also do you must continue to wash the
feet of other person's the customer that
time the washing of feet was one manner
to say welcome by persons arriving for
the supper and it was in Jesus was doing
this who is his disciples and you see
this sentence a model to follow done for
you should also do are very similar to
do this in memory of me and the world
memory is not there but desperation is
very very similar and it is it is the
question I think also as Christians the
recent mass do these two things the
memory memory of the present the present
of the past memory of Jesus and the
writer memory of the teachings of users
and the practice that is to say to
service
and and many other things linked to
these we have in the in the Gospels six
times is the only one place in the four
Gospels we have six times the presence
of one we call these normally a miracle
the multiplication of laws only one case
six times is a apparently curious in the
four gospel even John is the own own
only one with a clue in common with
other Gospels John and twice in Matthew
twice in mark enter do note only in a
very simple manner we can think this may
be this fact this multiplication of
Lance was a soul so strong for the
disciples they recall this because the
Gospels are memories the gospel our
memories of justice is a gospel but for
what reason so several times because
they have understood in this fact we are
in the heart of the good news and the
heart of the gospel to sinking in this
moment to the version of the Gospel of
John you remember the people we're
following Jesus this was preaching for
hours in one moment he says to the
disciples give you bread to these
persons to feed these persons and fats
answer of the disciples we have not
money
is to too many people we have not
resources to do that and Angie Schuster
asked insist ask this and we have after
what we call them eruption because one
little boy had five love of bread and
two fish I I love very much a fish in
the end the text for the reason because
we Christians when we listen bread
benediction Eucharist no no Jesus was a
very impressed by the hunger of the
people but kind of the estimate not a
spiritual hunger he was pitching for
hours it was a stomach and I'll say feat
bad too this is the question related to
you carry serpenti but only after and
people are eaten and we have it is
always in the text not ending journey in
the order there are very similar for the
four versions the two others in Matthew
Mark are another context but it's always
the same idea but another context oil
and it is said in the text after after
the people was eating we have 12 baskets
there well we can ask the question with
some nice day maybe for what reason 12
and not 11 or 12 and not 14 or five or I
don't know well it is difficult to say
that maybe
maybe you we take the context is because
12 is the figure of the people of God 12
tribals 12 disciples for the reason
there are 12 disciples and it will one
matter to say you continue to to do what
I have done the meaning of this text is
not exactly the multiplication but to
share is the miracle of share to share
Sharon Sharon even from very few things
five loaves of bread and two fish and
two to share it is the meaning of this
this text and to me to to share is to
service in this moment we can say really
it is a Malaysian with yoga risk because
to do the memory of Jesus's to recall
the witness of Jesus and washing of feet
east service and these two memories are
a key point to understand the witness
not only the winners of the middle but
the winners over every Christian they
are these two memories they are
interconnected certainly we know very
well traditional sentence the Eucharist
does the church well we can add in the
same sense for the same value the
washing of feet that is to say the
service the commitment to other persons
does the church course and it is not
only the Eucharist this little camera
celebration but the services is doing
also the Christian community many years
ago more than 40 years ago 46 the Pope
has written to has addressed this
message to 11 beaker feast the
participation in the Eucharist is a call
to correct to unjust inequalities
between persons sectors and nations as a
coal is not a besides if i have time i
am certain other person magnum is not so
they this you know I insist in this
because Romero was a man of the
Eucharist and homilies and but very
conscious about this relationship with
service who is commitment to other
persons and to a manly you remember
another short texts coming from the
Gospel of Matthew if when you are going
to present you offer to the altar you
remember you sibling has something
against you go first to reconcile with
your sibling and come after to present a
dual opening is not easy to find a
person's Sunday in the door of the
churches to Walter is not the custom but
it's clear if you remember because the
reconciliation who is siblings is a
condition to participate
a an toi I can read one text coming from
tomato you know this text is very
interesting because if the last words
the last big family of Romero was one
sunday in march the 24th but he was
assassinated monday Monday he was
celebrating the mass and was a mass for
able or lady he knew very well the
family and in this short homily in this
or for this mass for this lady Romero
has a this is the last because he was
shooted exactly after this this world
the body and the blood of Christ must
feed us to give our body and our blood
like Christ does not for our sellers but
in order to be committed to justice and
peace for our people we must be united
in the face and the whole of this prayer
for Donna Sarita and for us pinch this
moment he was killed it is very
interesting it seems to me enter
significant because the world very very
deep words justice peace commitment and
speaking about a poor person of of
Salvador very poor family aidonia Sarita
in this moment he was killed I think it
is sometimes we also try for for the so
many positions in the last hour
of Romero and even during the funeral I
have the opportunity to to attend the
funeral of Romero heroes killed one
Monday a llamar event el salvador
wednesday and the funeral Warsaw sunday
and the homily over the Mexican Cardinal
the sunday was interrupted and the mass
was not finished as the mass of the
assassination was not finished and our
calculation in the afternoon some hours
after the Salida the intrusion of this
was 40 40 person were killed during the
funeral well maybe a little more little
less maybe i have i have seen certain
death persons and behind me five and
using were terrible day certainly but
not only to take our affection why not
also but i think this man ha or have had
a soft deeper evangelical witness and
life it is really a guide for our
disciple a ship enter
to finish with the two memories I would
like to say this in this case of these
two memories will get no truce with Emma
choose one and to leave the other
because it will choose only one we are
losing both a table so I I am I can show
service no now in the memory according
to the Gospels they to do memory of the
life of Jesus is central question but
only Eucharist is not either is not
possible without Saturday's washing feet
we are not faithful to the message of
Jesus I would like to move now to the
second part fits tennety and history I
have a set several times different
moments the matter will also a pleasure
and good Alicia because sometimes his
homilies where during half hour a son
homilies 40 45 minutes you know one more
to one hour and it not easy for the
preachers today to do that because
people will events historical facts and
in his home lives we can find what was
happening in el salvador in those years
and you know in a very classic manner
his homeless how to sleep arts as the
first one the situation extra little
events it has happened this business
often with names interplays the dis
family and so on and
well second part a comment of the text
and taking trying to to illuminate the
situation from the text of that Sunday
and finally some applications what's
possible to do for this resulted
polarity they're listening and I would
like to take some ideas from Romero
about this question he has written this
desperation is coming from the Gospel of
Matthew 25 there is Ramirez speaking
there is a criterion to know if God is
close or far from us all those who are
concerned about the hungry one of the
naked one the poor person the missing
one the tortured one the prisoner of any
suffering flesh have got close to them
it is the criteria the criteria issue we
are concerned with the suffering persons
who is the insignificant person that is
close you see is the same idea in like
presentation from the beginning but this
man was not only preaching from
practicing this and for the reason he
was killed clearly the reason was
because he was acting as he was speaking
a speaking the same way they were also
taken commitments
I would like to say it would read some
short sentence from Romero here in El
Salvador where Christ is flesh and
related who suffers where Christ is
flesh who suffers it is again 925 if you
give food to a poor person you are
giving this to me and this
identification between Christ and the
the list it is the idea in this moment
we really want a church incarnated like
Jesus may refresh in the Salvadorian
reality I was always surprised reading
the humblest of Romero for this one
manner to speak of all persons flesh
they are flesh suffering fresh eyes
fresh I think that was very concrete and
you know the language when the language
is faithful to a reality is an
expression of the Israeli he says also
this in order to incarnate the Word of
God and the church we must be in
solidarity who is the pool and
insignificant people and this for him
the mean in the sense of history the
historical facts event in history we
must write to become really disciples of
Jesus
suffering was very present in the life
and in the homeless of Romero we can
understand so many people were were
dying healing really and we can
understand at the same time suffering is
the biggest challenge to resurface and
to human consciousness and I think we
have not a full answer to the suffering
above all the suffering of the innocent
people suffering is a fact they're
present and we try to illuminate a
little bit this question from our
classifieds but really is not easy and
we cannot say we have a full answer well
it is at least my position but outside
of person files the question is similar
I don't know even you have read some
book on novel of a great French writer
album all the novels of Camille were
about the question of suffering in
humanity he was not available and the
old was around this because grey
sensitivity certainly he was a Nobel
Prize or a moment but above all a very
close to to this so painful human
situation well it is true but at the
same time Romero was very clear about
this idea she has repeated several times
we were not created for suffering but
for happiness
and the conviction destroy it is
contrary to many experiences and reading
this I was thinking too from my my
experience as a parish priest in my
neighborhood I was 20 years in my last
parish above all women wear a ferment is
we women we born to suffer and I've also
struggling against this for 20 years
because this idea we were for suffered
they receive this poor person women they
receive this from their mothers and
their families in general this idea a
starting point is the biological point
aspect you can understand but this
terrible a person appearing I am born to
suffer and well I am not so optimistic
about the results of my strong you know
because these categories are very deep
very rooted and some results may be more
than some with the John women because
we're clear certainly now the other way
yeah maybe you're right you write bad
but because it's very you know the poor
person have a very disconnection a
reality is as stronger than us for
example they say often but unfortunately
i was born poor it is changing it is
true but this idea is very very strong i
was born so if you know a filming this
only one step more the Federation will
be it is the will of God to be pruned
and suffering it is the will of God well
I think Romero in the middle of so many
sufferings was speaking about happiness
several time and you know it's not so
innocent if you take this point of view
you are changing mentalities it is very
important I think Romero set or the
shepherd the pastor his case must be
there where are the suffering people but
he has never accepted suffering a trying
to the most radius to the people you are
suffering because were sinners or
because but not know always to say no
enter Jesus is not not come to this
world to suffer he he came to announce
the gospel and announcing the Nashville
he has met suffering it is a reason for
what item I I would like to avoid to
bless you eventual sensitivity but I
don't know what you think about this
film 23 years ago about the suffering of
Jesus the film of Egyptian terrible but
terrible is no Christian and more
suffering mass per more parcels observe
it is not possible a suffering a was the
price the cost a displeasure is coming
from duties Bonhoeffer German Lutheran
corrosion
a the cost of the discipleship the cost
surprise but though we are not here to
suffer and certainly because of it is a
fact we need to deal with this to
confront and to try to understand how to
live in a human manner in spite of
suffering I think it's very important to
you so to affirm to the poor people this
because otherwise life is a faith we are
doing some things because it is so and
you remember there is a beautiful
sentence and the amounts of justice in
the Gospel of John no one takes my life
from me I lay it down of my own free
will I have choose this choose to
announce the gospel not to suffer with a
macho suffering but will must be ready
to pay this price if it is necessary to
announce happiness kingdom joy to the
people it is the point and the
spirituality of Romero is not a
spirituality of suffering we call this
kind of persons markets Martino's
witness as you know but through
suffering well but it is true but to
look to look for martyrdom is not
written to accept hers is another thing
but were to be Marty is man Kristen
because it means to
to accept the presence of a hangman
executed it is not not listen to to want
to have one pillar and another right
French writer George Bernanos indeed I
love Carly lights has demonstrated is
very clear we cannot wish become matter
we can accept if is a price for the
house of the gospel but no more to
character sent is a piece of theatre one
jump sister analyte blanche and one all
sister and this all sister strong
personality his biggest wish was to
become Marty during the French
Revolution well at the end Blanche loss
Marty she was so afraid of this but she
was working and the order was alive and
you know I think we must in front of
suffering and in various a very
important case for this will clear and
go to the meaning all these questions I
would like to read a also text the offer
of Romero while it is clear that our
church has been the victim of
persecution during the last three years
he was our bishop only 3gs very short
time it is even more important to
observe the reason for a persecution not
only persecution of the reason for
the persecution comes about because the
church is taking the defense of the pool
because we are assuming the destiny of
the pool it is the cause of the
persecution and in this sense you know
primarily so maybe we can produce
another kind of martyr it is martyred of
the washing feet is the service but is a
memory to keep in mind and another
texture form of Romero when he has seen
his his days very close my last top
which kim was by phone and i have
finished the stock with a very not so
intelligent sentence i have set at the
enter well on senior happy to listen to
you take care little silence in the
phone and Romero says in order to take
care Gustavo I need to leave my country
and with the teacher was to stay
literally no because he was looking for
this but in order to defend the pool
after two other person who have the he
fails at this I have frequently been
threatened with death I'm ass thank you
as existing I do not believe in this but
in resurrection if they kill me I will
rise again the Salvadorian people I say
this without vanity with the greatest
humanely
a humidity as a pastor I have to give my
life for those who I love which are all
salvadorian people i would like to walk
to them to my third part about a hole
after this points about suffering and to
happiness because another another team
of the man to walk through to this
again one more attention from him if God
accepts my death I will be for the
liberation of my people and like a
testimony of hope in the future or these
the Christians have a great mission in
this hour of our country to maintain
hope hope is not an illusion that
impedes to see the reality on the
contrary how call us to watch the
reality with the eyes of the faith I
have mentioned this a new text from
homilies but you know he was very
committed in front of the events in
which country in the last weeks of his
life he has written for example a long
letter to the president of this country
in a time in our 80 februari 1980 please
stop arms for Salvador please no no no
no more because the army is buying
errands and to stop this and you see
were all only beautiful words sorta
logically speaking but taking position
very clear a about these questions well
about how to know in the chapter 32 of
the Book of Jeremiah we have a very
beautiful text in that moment the Jewish
people is
very bad situation between two powers
political and military powers Babylon in
the north Egypt and the south and it was
a war enter in the middle the Jewish
people and the people who live in the
country because was really destroyed in
that moment Jeremiah received the visit
of a cousin to him asking did you know
our uncle is dead and you are the first
person with a right to buy his land to
torino enter well but you by buying a
mount and these people destroying
particular it is just before what we
call the baronial exile well and no one
were buying nothing but going out and
jeremiah says maybe it is a sign to say
a hope in order to be to have really
hope we need to realize hope completely
are in this like buying a launch and he
he was doing this and i think hope is a
gift is a grace but without our
acceptance without our free will doesn't
signifies means nothing and to accept
the leaf of how means to create a
release
for hope and it this is the
understanding of over of Jeremiah we
need to do something very clearly
because we have hope and i think it is
our case today also it is impossible to
speak about romero without speaking
about our discipline of the put people
in the world certainly I know better the
situation of the Latin American people
but I think a whole is a very important
question for persons marginalized
persons despise persons and to create
reasons of how is the true manner to
receive the gift of hope and we must
when we must buy lunch we must to have a
concrete view and is not only we must
have hope not more concrete to do
something and I think it was the case of
over Romero and for the reason he is so
relevant important for us today as you
know it was water unfortunately the only
one case and these three bishops were
killed before Romero Angelelli from
Argentina after Romero Girardi from
Guatemala many priests nuns layperson
many to see San escandalo
latino military continent Christian why
formerly christian and catholic and
evangelical christian in this continent
we have a human poverty and we have the
summation over persons trying to change
this for christian reasons not only
wishes and please announce labors of the
catholic church while pastors also from
different evangelical churches well you
know this has come down this
contradiction to be a Christian and live
the majority of population in poverty is
one of the starting point over we called
the tellers of liberation this trilogy
was warned partially at least from this
contradiction because it true escandalo
well the witness of marriage feel about
this it seems to me from him we can say
the task of Christian churches is for
once I to criticize the growing of the
gap between rich nations and persons
poor countries and for persons and to
denounce the content for human dignity
for the insignificant people from other
side to contribute to rise the whole of
the poor and these two questions to
denounce what is comforting to the wheel
of life over the God of the Bible and
the other side
you nawlage the whole of the people are
I think they'd ask the of the church and
a very Christian two little things to
finish in order to create resource to
hope we must be free person's freedom is
not on the world belonging to the
political field freedom is a key word in
the second Testament in the New
Testament enter the second last point is
I see theology the reflection on our
face as a hermeneutic of hope heretic is
understanding well to do theology is to
reflect about the reasons for hoping for
to have hope well one reason certainly
among others it is true is the witness
as persons as Bishop Romero well I my
intention was to recall some point of
this great man and resistant thank you
thank you through several thank you very
much we have some time for questions and
answers and because this lecture is
being recorded I'm going to ask you to
use this microphone to ask a question
and please to help me pass the
microphone so who would like to begin I
remember being startled when I came
across in John Dominic Crossan birth of
Christianity is reading that Jesus was
speaking to people who were one step
from destitution telling them to share
with those who were destitute and I
wonder if you have any any thoughts on
that when we think about the
redistribution of resources
well I agree with this I think this
shading is very important and told you
no it is not necessary to have many
things in order to share because it is
the lesson of the text of the
multiplication of love because it is
possible to share from very very few
things is possible I think the destitute
to needs for example of friendship we
can say i have not more friendship to
give to to do well famil someone to make
senses and they pull out person with
many deprivation a great necessity of to
be listening to be welcome and was very
important I i am very different even the
commitment to the pool is not a same
time friendship wisdom because
friendship is one mana to share in
friendship suppose equality we have not
we we are not loving someone if I don't
consider this person equal to me equal
dignity and otherwise way I can protect
someone but love really friendship a
supposed equality and I i work very
impressed ones in my parish repairing
the feast of Christmas when all late
preparing
something to his talk to children of the
neighborhood when old lady told me you
know when I was child we were going to a
parish besides my own price at receiver
but no foot of bread rice milk and so
but one day 11 priest gave me a dollar
well I tension this moment is not to
enter the question for what reason dogs
are giving to varrick's and not boys I
know the question what is not my phone
now not not a young I have a position
about this also up is not as well and
these are this person told me you know i
remember the face of displaced she was
or five years old but you know adul were
lots of useful because the rice bread
milk with very good and bad for her hair
it was the first doll of his life as
gratuitous you know to offer to
destitute a foot to further persons our
friendship we close closeness to them I
think it's very important very important
not only to give material things also
also why not why not but not only not
only the poor are not only the object of
our charity but they are persons and
this is very very relevant very
important another question
it is quite honored to listen to your
excellent lecture and my question is
that in conclusion you said a theology
must be a hermeneutic overhaul if that's
the case what kind of ideological and
practical implication for relationship
with German theology and tricking
Ottomans theology abajo well this book
famous book of Jurgen and most one is
one expression of this but you know my I
furniture was more general in
meteorology even if I am NOT a filming I
am doing the College of hope no is
geology must be look must look for
reasons it isn't there in the letter of
repeated we must ready to explain the
reasons of our whole I think theology
must do this what is the resource of
hope and not only the conflict
oscillation as in salvador in many other
situations what the Book of Mormon is
going this way but I will be this more
than that even I am writing about
astrology is also won the
meaninglessness to to go to to it is the
dynamic memory of the present of the
past because to believe in Jesus Christ
it is very clear in event of Revelation
apocalipsis is home
another question thank you very much for
so many so many of the insights and
analysis in your lecture question about
the category as we rethink it of both
happiness and hope and I wonder if you
could reflect on the ways in which your
own very well known and well formulated
engagement with Marxist critical thought
and in particular critiques of
present-day market capitalism and how
with respect to the market in particular
in the commodity form it's precisely
happiness and hope that get taken over
and become the site of sort of the the
colonization of the market internal to
the self and could you talk about the
ways in which the happiness and the hope
that you described come into
conversation with those two other
articulations of what happiness and hope
consistent well it's a big question I am
maybe to take one on one point to try to
once a request to make thank you for
that it seems to me today in this sense
worse than some decades ago in the
beginning of liberation theology and we
are going to a work of excluded persons
and not significant for the market and
don't be significant for the market isms
or not exist particularly in mentality
and I think this is cluded for me are a
big challenge for these two questions
happiness and home what is possible to
speak out hope to these persons
I remember this little anecdote in one
innocent community and person world
speaking very poor persons some with
some work a daughter without work and
people working we're seeing this I
decided I study will adjust and so I am
a press person and another without
employment Jesus a young I am not even a
place they are nothing exists I am
looking for an oppressor and this and
unjust salary at least anyway I have a
deep sense of humor certainly at the
same time but terrible well how to speak
up to these people is not only suffering
operation hunger and soul but at the
same time to be nothing well I think
this moment it is not to be against
globalization to make sense again
brigands globalization as such is to be
against electric energy not make sense
but the manner and how the globalization
is conducted in this cases and we have
these non relevant persons well it's not
easy and to recall their human dignity
to recall the condition of children of
God well is not pausing to do that only
a feeling this very child of God would
thank you what
Italy what is the meaning of this and I
was in my parish for long time preaching
under this the reticle question were
very useful for me to keep this in mind
oh wait and one one day during my homily
one person I feel me you you are really
a great humorist because you say God
love us by preference we are the first
anywhere in this neighborhood and you
know our condition delivers you are an
arrest it was a contradiction is
terrible you know very theoretical my
people is very polite for this question
never never maybe personally one day
from one person but never in the church
but for reals priest was very important
to avoid only words and well is a big
challenge a big challenge I think that
is not too long a full answer the
friendship wisdom is very important
because in one manner to to say for me
you are a person not only to say forgot
you are a person not for me to wear very
concrete is not enough I recognize and
at the same time any person even the
poorest have some sense of happiness
they know little humble joys the the
poor person I'm not only victims they
are not crying all day it is not true do
nobody when the Fiesta and no i did not
true well water to to elaborate starting
from deals i think is very important but
is not easy it is a day
we work in the only personal work when
we are working with cool persons which
that way you mentioned the word fiesta
and we're going to move the conversation
more informal fiesta and we're going to
invite everyone to meet you upstairs on
the second floor for a little food and
drink and to be sure
you